>> Can India become a superpower?
I'm not sure that India would really want
to be a superpower.
If India thought about its prosperity in the
right way.
India is looking to a period of 8, 9 percent
growth [INAUDIBLE]
And India's main priority surely should be
to increase the life
circumstances of its own people, increasing
health services, increasing
education, making sure that the hundreds of
millions of people who live
on less than $3 a day in rural areas have
their life chances improved.
Improving educational, economic opportunities
for women, managing what
is second largest degree of organization that
the world has ever seen.
So all of those are major, major challenge
for this Indian government
and future Indian leaders.
And if I was India, I'd concentrate on meeting
those challenges before
worrying about whether it is a superpower.